tensions are climbing between russia and
the west over concerns moscow is
planning to invade ukraine soon over the
weekend the u.s ordered family members
at its embassy in kiev to leave the
country russian president vladimir putin
denies that he's planning an invasion
but ukraine's ambassador to the uk tells
bloomberg otherwise
we don't believe what
russian said putin is saying just not
because he's on his own territory which
he's claiming but problem is that we're
missing the point that he's been in
ukraine and was fighting with us for
last seven years we're not going all the
way into history but this seven years
already costed us more than thirteen
thousand people dead and seven percent
of territory so why would we believe him
right now
the new york times is reporting
president biden is now considering
deploying troops to eastern europe and
the baltics and sending warships and
aircraft to nato allies so let's get an
on-the-ground perspective from peter
dickinson a ukraine editor at the
atlantic council peter is a british
national who spent more than two decades
living in ukraine and he joins us now
from kiev peter i want to start with the
most recent reports that the white house
may now send thousands of u.s troops uh
to nato allies in anticipation that
russia will move forward with some kind
of invasion that would be a major major
pivot from biden's
previous stance what does that potential
shifted strategy signal to you
well it would be a significant strategy
shift because ukraine i'm sorry nato has
always despite russia's protestations
and and complaints
uh nato has always been very careful
about the amount of troops that it does
station in countries uh close to russia
bordering on russia and in the region in
central and eastern europe so it would
be a major step in uh towards uh a much
stronger native nato presence in the
region which of course is exactly what
uh vladimir putin says he wants to avoid
so there's a certain amount of irony
that his actions may be provoking uh the
the outcome that he most sought to uh to
prevent
um but even so i would i would uh
caution uh reading too much into it
because the numbers are still quite
small you have to bear in mind that
russia at the moment has a master force
close to ukraine
around the country of approximately 100
to 150 000 men uh you know so a few
thousand extra american troops in
central and eastern europe are well
welcomed certainly for the nato
countries in question and also from a
ukrainian point of view i'm not going to
tip the balance that's a good point but
going back to that
idea that there are about 150 100 000
u.s or i should say russian troops in
ukraine along the border that sounds
like a lot but is it enough to
accomplish uh a land invasion if that's
what putin is planning
well that's a good question and the
short answer is no probably not at this
stage ukraine is a huge country it's the
largest country wholly in europe it's a
massive land mass
so talk of a so-called full-scale
invasion and an attempt essentially by
russia to fully occupy the country
military military analysts
are not in total agreement but the
general figure you hear bandied about is
is between maybe three and five hundred
thousand troops would be necessary for
such an operation uh i'd be inclined to
put it towards the higher end of that
scale towards half a million now russia
has nothing like that many troops in in
play uh it would even be a question
whether russia could muster that many
troops i mean they have such soldiers
they have they have more than a million
men technically but russia is also a you
know vast country they need to they need
to secure
the whole the whole of the country they
can't deploy the
their entire military in ukraine as it
were so
uh the force they have at the moment
perhaps is looking for
slightly more limited objectives but
there are many they could do there are
many different uh uh slightly less
ambitious operations that they could
accomplish with this force such as what
peter
um
one would be a land bridge between the
area that's occupied unofficially by
russia and east ukraine and the crimean
peninsula essentially these two two
positions that russia already holds in
ukraine to connect them via a land
bridge
they could look to take over other parts
of southern ukraine they could look to
have an incursion another point on the
border perhaps uh hardkey for example is
ukraine's second largest city it's only
a stone's throw from the russian border
in the east um of course taking a city
is a city of around one and a half
million people so that would be a huge
undertaking again but these are all
options on the table uh that russia has
you know the the full-scale invasion is
only one of many different options right
right do you think putin has already
determined what he's going to do or a
lot of it will depend on how the u.s
responds whether the u.s sends troops to
nato whether nato speaks with the
unified voice i mean how much of this is
predetermined versus a
play-by-play
well this is the this is the big
question you know we're all we're all
trying to become uh mind readers these
days of of of putin trying to get inside
his head and work out where he's going
and what his plans are my personal
instinct is yes he has not fully decided
i think there's certainly a strong
element of intimidation going on here
that putin believes the west is weak uh
collectively he believes they will
ultimately fold so he's increasing the
pressure he's increasing the tensions
hoping that ultimately the west will
fold and give him uh sweeping
concessions
but that does not mean he is not
prepared to also go to the the active
military phase if need be i think
certainly he's looking at the moment to
see what the west will do in response
he's looking for signs of disunity he's
looking for signs of weakness
he's looking for readiness to compromise
now if he doesn't see any of that he's a
very strong united front from the west
it may give him cause to think twice
but it may not because i think the west
has been quite clear collectively
america and britain as well have been
quite clear that they will not send
troops to ukraine to fight with you you
know alongside ukrainians against russia
so the the
the the measures that putin is really
expecting to encounter are almost
exclusively finite of the financial
nature high sanctions
which might not be enough to deter it
russia has huge reserves built up
specifically to whether a major
sanctions storm yeah that pain might be
worth it for him peter ukraine is
dominating the headlines uh here in the
u.s it feels like last week was a real
inflection point and is now reportedly
one of the reasons why the u.s stock
market is plunging as well what does
washington and the rest of the u.s get
wrong misunderstand the most about the
situation on the ground in the ukraine
well i think that there's this there's a
lot of talk about the geopolitics
there's a lot of talk about putin about
what culture wants there's a lot of talk
about uh the actions of the west of nato
i think fundamentally if we if we look
at if we step back and look at this
whole crisis at the very heart of this
crisis we have the ukrainian people it
is their will and their agency here
that's driven this whole thing they are
the ones who sought to establish a
democracy
uh who sought to turn their country
towards euro atlantic integration to
join the eu
to establish a democratic system and
these are the reasons why putin has
has attacked the country beginning in
2014
because putin does not wish to see a
country so close historically to russia
but have a successful transition away
from authoritarianism to
uh european democracy and so he's very
very much um
committed to preventing ukraine from
making this transition he understands
that it's essentially it's an
existential threat to his own regime his
own authoritarian regime um and the
ukrainian people are very determined to
to continue with the path that they've
set out on and they won't change you
know if the west was for example were to
make some sort of a deal or try to make
a compromise with russia then the west
would then turn around and find the
ukrainian people would quite likely say
no sorry we're not going to accept this
ultimately fundamentally that's the
bottom line of this story the ukrainian
people are we should not underestimate
their agency
very important point you know i made a
mistake when i spoke just now calling it
the ukraine which is something that
people in the us do a lot and i think
that speaks to how um uneducated we are
about ukraine and culturally how
how close it is to russia i mean
vladimir putin has made the point that
ukraine and russia share very close
historical ties cultural ties even
from where you sit having lived in
ukraine for last for the last 20 years
does it look like that there on the
ground or has it changed a lot
well it certainly looked more like that
20 years ago than it does now
and i think that the ukraine is probably
the greatest of europe's uh historic
captive nations it was a as i mentioned
it's a huge country but it was
essentially dominated by foreign powers
primarily but not exclusively russia but
mostly russia for hundreds and hundreds
of years uh and during that period the
russians uh
regardless of whether it was the tsar
the czarist regime or then the soviet
regime afterwards they all shared uh
very strong uh policies of russification
um you know so the russian language
dominated russian culture dominated the
ukrainian ukrainian was reduced to the
level of it was
it was a kind of a dialect it was often
described as it was not you know you
have to speak russian to get on and uh
culturally historically they were always
promoted the idea that the countries
were you know ukraine was essentially a
a subgrouping of russia and so for many
many years this this went on and it's
only now over the last 30 years ukraine
is is making efforts to reclaim its
history so you shouldn't be too hard on
yourself for perhaps you know not
getting the correct challenge because
people do and people here do it
sometimes as well you know okay
because it's it's it's a process that's
very much ongoing and yeah it's part of
the reason we are where we are today
that ukraine's attempts to assert its
own uh identity uh put it in conflict
with russia you know russia regards kiev
it's important to remember russia
regards kiev as the mother city of
russia it's the home of it's the
birthplace of the russian nation so
uh
in a foreign country obviously
undermines russia's own claims and
ukrainians will say to russians well you
know actually
russia's roots are are to the east are
with the mongol empire
and the moscow's rise as a vassal state
of the mongol empire so
history is the history goes very very
deep in this and uh there are a lot of
intertwined uh moments in russian
ukrainian history but what we're seeing
now is essentially geopolitical divorce
and those divorces can be painful peter
i really appreciate your taking the time
to explain all that in the historical
context is fascinating peter dickinson
is ukraine editor at the atlantic
council he joins us from kiev